hello YouTube just love us and my
friends this is grunge in here and today
I'm going to show you a trap in a French
advance variation the advance medicine
start when Wyatt's kick start with E for
and black responds with the e6 and the
line continues with the D for define
here wide closed the center with the he
file black general response is quickly
undermined the white pawn chain by
playing c5 and the general line
continues with the moves like c3 but our
trap line it's continued the knight to
f3 as a French player you don't really
want to capture that D pawn you would
more prefer rather putting your queen on
b6 and knight on c6 where it pressurized
more on the D pawn and before going into
this trap let me tell you something
nowadays there are lots of five minutes
and three means giv have been playing
and in those games what generally people
tend to do is they come out with their
favorite pet lines or their favorite six
seven moves so what they try to achieve
by doing that is you just want to save
some time in opening so where they can
spend some more time in the middle game
and here where this kind of craps are
really effective so I strongly recommend
you that if you playing a blitz or the
three minutes game just shock your
opponent with this kind of crap okay
Ilia as a French player they more prefer
in at this point they more prefer a
moves like Queen to b6 and the usual
line continues like point to c3 Knight
to c6 and here white has a nice cunning
move which is Bishop to d3 and if the
black is not aware of this scenario and
maybe white can trick him for example if
the black things that he can win a pawn
here like pawn takes pawn and white
captures back and if the black knight
take this pawn white knight can
immediately take the knight and here if
the black Queen take this knight black
loses the Queen by this
the bishop check so that's why nowadays
there is a model way to tackle this so
as a prior French player
what they do is play a moves like Bishop
to d7 after we play Knight to f3 so what
this mu does is like it's just a
preparation move for Queen to b6 and
Knight to c6 and also is block a deadly
check of the bishop so the other way
another way to think is what black is
just a waiting move which is hoping that
white do some kind of mistakes and he
can jump on Hornaday and here white will
continue with the d3 Bishop to d3 and if
the black continue with his favorite
bait lines like Knight to c6 then we can
shock him with this move Knight to g5
and especially when you playing family
so Truman's game the immediate response
from the black case just kick this knife
what is actually doing here well maybe
as a black bear you think that while
white is after that H's haven't born so
why not kick this night and if they play
move like at 6 or the f6 they will come
to a blunder house and here our chest
trap works so as a wide you will play
Queen to h5 and now you see that that
pawn cannot take the knight because it
spin because for example let's say black
take this night then we can catch the
rook and we are exchanged up and not
only that here white is threatening or
f7 mate
now that two ways to defend this let's
take the first option is which is the
worst option is like moving this point
further well here white can simply take
this pawn the bishop and if the like
let's say black capture this Bishop then
we can capture do capture by the Queen
and this is check and King has only one
place to go where it
checkmate in by the white and for
instance here if he didn't want to
capture that Bishop and he wants to move
over here then maybe we can simply take
this pawn it's just a [ __ ] Queen in a
group so white we'll have a nice game
from here but it's not always the case
as a black player you might think okay
it's not a big deal
I can like you don't save this f7
checkmate by putting my queen over here
he's seven but here White has another
shocking move which is simply capture
this point by the knight and now the
black feel like you know wake up from
his dreamland because he probably now
realized that he is in serious trouble
because that Knight is unshakable if the
black by mistake take this night he
simply loses the Queen by the bishop so
that night is unthinkable and I just
want to have a look let's say if you are
black and if you fall into this trap how
you feel
look at the black queer like Kings side
pieces this Queen this King it's stuck
here it cannot do a queenside castle
this queen is also stuck it has no place
to hide this Bishop is behind the screen
and upon so it cannot move this Knight
has no place to go and this rope is just
waiting that that been captured by the
night it's just a hopeless position in
just eight more the game so this is
really terrible and that was the first
option for the white and let's say here
the black player instead of at six he
player f6 then here white will still
continue with the Queen check and if the
King goes to the let's say seven square
this is straight away checkmate and if
this I like black decided to play the g7
then we will take this pawn by the
bishop and if the King move over here
we already see in the previous game that
we can move this night over here but in
this case it's not a workout so why it
has to play this captured is at seven
and white we'll have a good game from
here and the other option is let's say
here if the black capture this Bishop by
mistake then still it will be checkmated
by the void so this is a really nice
trap and I can't tell you how many
people are fall into this trap
I have seen people radiate over 1700
easily fall in this trap so just try
this try this trap in you especially if
you playing 5 minutes so the three
minutes game and it really works feel
free to comment on my video and thank
you for watching my video
see you bye